see ya
hello good evening and welcome to the
latest total war Warhammer campaign
walkthrough video today we're going to
take a snapshot of a campaign we've been
playing as the Empire and the usual
caveats apply were still a good two and
a half months from launch and well into
bouncing and polishing so you may see
some placeholder bits and bobs and many
of the values on show may well change as
we nudge everything into place okay so
we're 71 turns into the game here and as
you can see from the overview map we own
the full provinces of Reich land and
mid-atlantic by conquering right land
and we've recently taken the three
regions of Midland from the faction of
Hawk land who just weren't playing ball
diplomatically which frankly is their
loss in terms of our immediate neighbors
we can see that Britannia has been
rather badly ganged up on and pretty
much taken out of the picture the
vampire faction of MU salon has emerged
the strongest here while bordello is
very much in the game still as our art
orphan chums of Carrick nor this Inland
rules to the east and beyond them the
vampire factions who are breaking out of
the Sylvanian provinces towards us
looking at the diplomatic status overlay
we're feeling relatively secure at the
moment all factions mops blue are our
allies Testaments and good treaty making
on our part early on just north you can
see the skull takers a roving tribe of
savage orcs who tore into our territory
some turns earlier but we managed to
send them packing
so with friends around us but vampire
enemies in the mix too there's all to
play for guarding our northernmost point
of expansion and providing much-needed
public order to the newly conquered and
therefore unstable province of Midland
is Emperor Karl Franz himself he's got a
fairly well balanced low to mid tier
army with him composed of great swords
swordsmen crossbowmen rights guard and
mounted pistol ears Carl himself is
currently equipped with the sword of
swift saying a Charmed shield and an
obsidian lodestone which offers him some
magical resistance on the battlefield
skills wise we've been focusing largely
on improving his combat abilities making
him an all-round better warrior and
we've unlocked his early mounts so let's
upgrade his Pegasus for a tasty buff to
its charge bonus
otherwise the only other skill we've
given him is in his campaign tree which
helps his army to march further on the
campaign map each turn we've yet to
tackle his quest chains and earn his
epic here but we'll definitely be making
time for those soon as the buffs on them
as you can see are pretty major now each
race has its own set of campaign
mechanics and something that's unique to
the Empire is its offices which we can
see here on the opposite panel Lords and
legendary loads are the only character
types who can be assigned to these roles
and the only character who can be
promoted to the office of Emperor is of
course Carl Franz for fairly obvious
reasons other lords can be assigned when
they reached the level requirements as
well so let's assign felix von erich
unto the office of treasurer now this is
going to boost trade income faction wide
for us and any infrastructure income in
any friendly region he's inhabiting
there's a number of other panels we can
check up here but we're going to look at
the forces tab and find Felix in our
list of characters so there is and we
can see his new title has been added to
his name in fact let's rename him to
something ever more befitting his new
station in life
I think that should do it you can rename
all your characters except your
legendary Lords of course now okay let's
head back over towards alt Dorf and
we're going to have a look at the empire
tech tree in a bit more detail so text
in the empire tech tree are unlocked as
you build specific buildings so once
you've built a rally field for example
it offers buffs to our core infantry as
does the barracks the blacksmith
improves weapon and armor upgrades of
various units so let's go ahead and
crack on with researching improved light
CAV armor now alt Dorf is your starting
city as the empire and the provincial
capital but it's the only city that you
do start with and to be honest your
first turns are probably going to be
spent building up your forces and
looking to expand and capture the
entirety of hwhiteland I think we had
all these settlements under control by
around turn 20 much of our focus since
then has been on improving our
infrastructure to unlock better units
and boost our income here in the
building browser for outdoor who can see
what we've built and of course what
we're driving towards in terms of
recruitment income is derived from our
capital city various cash generating
buildings in outer settlements plus any
exploitable resources in the region
we've got some play pits in outdoor fair
for example so that's contributing
towards our trade tariffs and if we
examine Gruenberg here we can see that
certain chains are limited by the
maximum size of the settlement and with
pastures in this region we can use
cattle to bring some good growth and
replenishment benefits to the province
standing resolute outside outdoor fizz
our second legendary Lord Balthazar gilt
who is currently being harassed by a
Kaos hero character the heat rather
aptly named fate or death metal we only
recently recruited Balthazar to our
campaign so he's pretty low level still
but we can see from his skill tree that
he's very much magically focused and the
more law knowledgeable amongst you may
recognize Balthazar's epic gear in his
questions here now obviously what we
want to get in casting spells in battle
so we're going to unlock the spells
searing doom and Gehenna golden hounds
both of which are offensive spells
now we're gonna stick Balthazar in
outdoor for now where he'll contribute
to public order for a while a quick
glance over at our neighbors here
reveals the influence of vampiric Musel
on corruption is spreading and twisting
the foliage into something will vamp
friendly now as we saw in the overview
map we have some vamps to our east too
and in fact our midterm game plan here
is to keep our local loyalty solid so we
have some friends call on if things
start getting a bit too bitey on the
Border's one last stop on our brief tour
then and we're going to head north east
where we have one of our empire captain
heroes on an exploratory mission towards
the chaos wastes now rupert sunscribe
here is making good progress into
uncharted lands and he really isn't that
far from the chaos wastes now and the
mere presence of chaos is starting to
twist the land as well and just north of
Rupert here we can see just how that's
happening black rocks are rising from
the stony earth lava flows are opening
up and arcane artifacts are beginning to
appear add in the bit of weather up this
way which only gets worse the further
north you go and you're looking at a
pretty inhospitable and attritional
landscape ok that's all for now we hope
you've enjoyed this gameplay snapshot
and do keep tabs on our social media
channels for more campaign and battle
videos coming your way very soon
you